the results for Republicans  um how much of that will be because of  Donald Trump  well I think if they win I should get  all the credit and if they lose I should  not be blamed at all okay but it'll  probably be just the opposite he he sang  it with a straight face guys  he's not joking it's just like with  covid where he said I don't take any  responsibility  he's not joking when they win I think  they're going to do very well I'll  probably be given very little credit  even though in many cases I told people  to run and they ran and they turned out  to be very good candidates you know  they've turned out to be very good  candidates but usually what would happen  is when they do well I won't be given  any credit and if they do badly they  will blame everything of me so I'm  prepared for anything but we'll defend  ourselves what a victim